new mouton cheese aisle Charles Xavier
and the Wolverine
we got ourselves an x-men fan
you will not divide
I hear that a lot you probably hear this
too more than I'd like
Logan water or not vomiting justin
trudeau
turn off the world is not the same as it
was you
they're gonna
logan she reminds you of anybody being
Hong Kong dong-won
[Music]
Oh we'll have time
see youtubers is Charlie knew Logan
footage teasing New Mutants there's a
whole bunch of Deadpool and other x-men
stuff happening let's break it down the
really cool thing here is is a whole
bunch of 9t stuff happening in this clip
there's a whole bunch of 9t stuff
happening in the x-men movies in real
life this year so I'll explain
everything in there is a new round of
the Logan giveaways for IMAX gift
certificates all explained that at the
end of the video but this is a hat tip
to the new Mutant comic book from the
90s who is she she's one of the new
mutants they're making a new mutants
movie right now it was even some concept
art of Maisie Williams as wolf spayed
one of the characters appearing in that
movie they're going to be shooting this
year I'll talk about it in a second I
don't think that x-23 is going to appear
in the new mutants movie just because
this is that so much later in the
timeline but then you get a better look
at Donald Pierce's characters the
enhanced cyborg leader of the rebirth
who he himself ran afoul of the new
mutants he had a big beef against the
x-men because he was white bishop of the
Hellfire Club in the comics the new
mutants foiled his plan so he vowed
revenge and went on this killing rampage
trying to get all the x-men so the Logan
movie has changed a lot of that but it's
so funny how in a meta way all these
things that are happening in real life
in the x-men universe tie together in
this movie in the context of this clip
you have Vander Rice here who's the
leader of this Weapon X offshoot who's
been creating all these new mutants
including x-23 he's a character that
debuted her solo comic book and it looks
like he's co-opted the Reavers from the
comics who debuted during uncanny x-men
you know completely different title in
the world of this movie he's enhanced
them in the way that he's trying to beef
up everyone else like William Stryker
did so we'll see what they have to do
with the stuff that's come before with
the Weapon X program because they did
change the timeline quite a bit I know
it's a little confusing so when the
movie comes out I'll try to explain what
Days of Future past changed it changed a
few things because the biggest question
I get is how did he get his metal claws
after Days of Future past before x-men
apocalypse even more cool stuff from the
90s if you were a fan of the 90s car 2
I used to watch it after school on Fox's
afternoon programming block they eat the
plate in the afternoon Lady Deathstrike
was a big character during season three
as that show she became this big
antagonist for Wolverine they had this
crazy backstory where she used to be a
character called Yura code that he was
in love with her father forced her to
undergo these enhancements she got
brainwashed became Lady Deathstrike so
it was this big WTF twist what you've
done to yourself beautiful I did it for
you really go know the Yuriko you knew
no longer exists I am Lady Deathstrike
now a living weapon of ribbon what but
in the comics after the Reavers get
reformed under Donald Pierce after he
leaves the Hellfire Club they start
working for her so it all ties around to
this Wolverine canon
the animated series always changed
things just a little bit the movies are
obviously changing things just a little
bit aligning the Reavers with this
Weapon X program so I'll try to
straighten it all out when the movie
comes but it's just so much fun to think
about all this 90's x-men stuff so
looping it back around to the larger
x-men universe right now in real life
x-men supernovae was confirmed by sophie
turner to be filming later this year in
the producer confirmed that it's going
to take place during the 90s ten years
after the last x-men apocalypse movie
almost certainly confirming that they're
going to be starting the Dark Phoenix
arc they didn't talk about sequels
because it's a really big story it would
be really hard for them to cram that all
into a single movie so I am happy that
they're following up on the Phoenix art
because Jean Grey manifested the Phoenix
at the end of Apocalypse I'm okay if
they want to reboot things if they want
to retool creatively behind the scenes
but what I'd really like to see is then
push into outer space in the way that
Marvel has with the starjammers the
Shiar Empire that's all part of the Dark
Phoenix arc so it's a really important
part of that character but that is
light-years away from the Logan movie so
it's completely separate so you probably
won't
here a whole lot of official things
about that till after the Logan movie
comes out and they'll also be dropping
some Deadpool to bomb because that movie
is going to be shooting later this year
- they still haven't confirmed who cable
or Domino is going to be but they're
really close Ryan Reynolds keeps teasing
things they just had the big Deadpool
anniversary the one-year anniversary
from when it came out he posted this
toilet paper joke so just expect a lot
of funny Deadpool stuff to be happening
later this year - what I'm really
looking forward to though is like the
non teaser e things that he did from
behind the scenes like he was just
hanging out with this group of children
this wasn't an official promo but it was
the best thing ever
you may be wondering why I brought you
here at some point we must all join
forces become a team now how many of you
have taken a human life what in the g
sock it holds your name ray-ban Samir
alright give you wonder with your
superpower let's skip it
^ never heard back to the one what stop
it that's cool dancing oh yeah we're
gonna fight crime maybe start a little
crime
we're going to get out there we're going
to kick a little ass this is the magical
x-men oh one two three
okay guys team photo look straight ahead
guys
read ahead you have to imagine him
explaining that middle finger to all
those little kids parents but there's
going to be all kinds of stuff like this
later this year and that's one of the
things that I think made people love
Deadpool so much even if they weren't
super familiar with the character he has
this hardcore fan base but Ryan Reynolds
totally want everyone else over with
this hardcore commitment to that
character so I'll be doing a bunch for
Deadpool to stuff really soon well let
me know in the comments which new x-men
movie are you most excited about now you
have to imagine that they're going to be
changing a lot of the look and feel of
the x-men movie universe especially
because all these new characters are
coming in but I feel like New Mutants is
actually going to be pretty rad it'll be
a smaller movie than the main x-men film
so I think it has a lot of opportunities
to surprise people in the way that
Deadpool did but as we get closer to the
Logan movie is there are any other big
x-men things from the comics that you
guys want me to talk about or characters
or x-23 things just let me know in the
comments and just because there's so
much x-men related stuff happening right
now that's really cool there's even a
lot of TV stuff happening that I haven't
had a chance to talk about yet there's a
lot of other Marvel TV stuff I'll try to
fit it in when I can but just let me
know in the comments if there's anything
that you guys really really want me to
do videos about that I haven't done a
video about yet there's a new round of
the Logan giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video is for IMAX gift
certificates congratulations to the new
win or two from last week the bomb
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details it was a new round that
started in this video I'll announce the
winner the next time I post an x-men
video I've got some new Game of Thrones
that I'll be posting later tonight so
it's going to be a really busy week of
comic book stuff it's going to be a lot
of fun while you wait for that you can
click here to see the video I did on
that new mutants teaser and you can
click here for brand new guardians of
the galaxy - thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you in the next video
you